because of you we raised twenty thousand
one hundred and eighty dollars for the
alzheimer's association that is
astonishing it's not fundraising oh no
it's hair raising
the fight to end alzheimer's is personal
to me and it's the mission of everything
i do with the curiosity box it tickles
brains and enriches them in our newest
box i found a way to make impossible
colors finally easy to experience two
different colors fight for the rights to
your perception and you have no control
over it it's like you're watching your
brain operate independently of your
consciousness
i want to end this year with a big push
so right now if you join with code best
you'll get our new box but you'll also
get our best of box completely free
thank you for being a part of this
effort thank you for thinking and caring
and as always
thanks for watching